he's an investor partner or adviser to a
multitude of businesses through his book
club and podcasts he shares advice on
how to achieve health wealth love and
happiness he says that finding mentors
is one of the biggest predictors of your
success
he's Tai Lopez and here are his top ten
rules for success life is very short
I see people going oh I'm 22 I only have
you know I have all the world in front
of it you don't first of all tomorrow's
not guaranteed but more importantly they
age with which people are starting to
become entrepreneurs I read there's a
kid he made a nuclear power plant in San
Francisco he's 17 years old
that's your new competitor so increase
your sense of urgency as an intangible I
need to practice remember before the day
comes you got to practice you cannot be
standing at the free-throw line playing
professional basketball in the seventh
game of the NBA championship and to hope
right then you're going to be practiced
practice is too late Larry Bird used to
put the great basketball player he used
to shoot whatever thousand free-throws
8:00 in the morning my friend Don ravine
trains a lot of the pro basketball
players LeBron James he trains uh he
trains Durant
Kobe Chris Paul and he said these guys
are up when everybody else is sleeping
they're practicing so everything you
want is gonna entail a good bit of
practice so the second thing you have to
do is people have to understand
insurance and I'm not just talking about
life insurance or health insurer I'm
saying you have to protect what you
already have so some people like Warren
Buffett says you don't have to get rich
once so when you do well and you make
money have insurance by save some of it
for a rainy day that's insurance I did a
video on it like that was the most
important because it was a few times in
my life where I got like really I was a
really high up your pyramid you know
right and then fell back yeah and I feel
bad I I did a video of it maybe I'll put
a link in it into the description three
times I went like up way up here me and
fell back
yeah I didn't insurance well now
you now you can tell people don't fur
and Mark Cuban who became a billionaire
he owns the Dallas Mavericks and
different stuff
he sold a company or like a sports radio
program and he was probably uh shares of
Yahoo and at the when he got so they
paid him all these shares which were
worth a lot of money at the time but you
know shares can go up and down so he had
one mentor a financial advisor who said
don't listen you should buy insurance on
this so there's a way to do that with
stock options and sure enough those
shares of Yahoo had been paid in dropped
to almost worthless but he had locked in
the value with insurance so he's still
the billionaire we know now so lock in
what you have increase your courage
harden up a little bit take a cold
shower don't always take a warm shower
acclimate your mind and your body to
doing things that are harder you know
one of my friends who's one of the most
successful people in the young startup
but made a billion dollar valuation on a
company of five years whenever we're
talking about new ideas we're going to
do next if I say oh that's going to be
easy why don't we do that he says tight
there's no money in what's easy focus on
these intangibles you know the ability
to have a ton of courage he said the
secret to advice I mean the sacred to
success is get hold of something and
hang on
just hang on if somebody wants it hang
on to it it's worth as much to you as it
is to anybody who wants it I have to
think in the world now or everybody's
idea of a business is a make a business
I'm going to buy a piece of real estate
on a flip it I'm going to do it one week
later I'm going to buy a stock and short
sale this guy had a completely different
approach get a hold of something and
hang on to it and if you look at some of
the most successful people in the world
they follow that strategy Bill Gates
gave up very little shares in Microsoft
he owned I think 60% of it even at its
peak he may have sold since then but he
got ahold of something and didn't didn't
let go and he says and again that's the
opposite of mentality and most people
have Warren Buffett has the same thing
he buys businesses that he would want to
hold on
- forever you got to get good we talked
about this getting good at one thing but
this guy was saying I've heard this this
is a new member I said you got to create
voices in your head this is a voice this
Jack Simplot I want they even put on the
back of the grab a hole to something and
hang on if you don't have something to
grab a hold of you better freak out and
find something to grab hold on it can be
an occupation can be a movement or be a
charity you can be a business it can be
an invention it could be a piece of art
but grab hold of something and do not
let go now make sure you grab onto the
right thing because if grab a wrong
thing uh you're in for some trouble but
have some investment don't spend all
your cash so that you want a good deal
comes up you have the money to buy if
you're an artist if you're farmer if
you're a actor or whatever you're gonna
need some cash don't spend the taught
and get a hold of something people are
successful have extraordinary
imaginative vision and Elon Musk calls
it a more complicated term which is
arguing from first cause it's not
analogy so here's what arguing from
analogy or not having an extraordinary
imaginative vision let's say you're in a
horrible place you were sleeping in your
car yeah I was sitting on my couch
someone born and get us someone born in
poor part India if you argue from um
announced re arguing from analogy means
well everybody around me is doing bad
I'm doing bad therefore I'm gonna always
do bad that's arguing from analogy and
that's not having imaginative vision the
people who make are the people who do
the opposite they go I'm gonna argue
from first cause I'm going to say has
anybody ever written a written are risen
up from the ashes out of the ghetto or
from the couch or from the car the
answer is we all know that story so if
somebody else did it then if you use
extraordinary creative imagination then
why can't you do it do and that's
arguing from first causes that's what
allowed Elon Musk to make Tesla
spaceships Solar City so for all of us
we get stuck
when we argue from analogy well you know
last time I started a business it failed
last time I trusted somebody they
betrayed me well that's good that's
arguing from a now justice saying
because it happened before it's gonna
happen it doesn't always work that way
sometimes you do it better you double
down on your brain you learn from the
mistakes of others and your mistakes and
the next thing you create something new
and that's where wealth come from not
just wealth in your bank account wealth
of happiness love health everything you
want remember change your mind change
your life everybody wants to change life
but you have to change your mind
humans are different because we have
powerful minds and sometimes I guess is
in trouble but if you pull it off right
it can bring you those things that you
need in life those things that you're
missing you know everybody wants the
good life like I say my TEDx talk
everybody wants the good life but not
everybody gets the good life because
most people are willing to do this stuff
that it takes and I willing to put in
the time put in the grind
do not be a 450-pound person making fun
of other people for being overweight
focus on yourself and learn from the
world don't take that attitude uh-huh oh
really
nobody great is going to prove their
point to you for the most part they're
gonna say what they have to say this
guy's dead he does not care what you
think about his book if you're able to
go through this and glean three things
that change your life forever
then that's great for you so have that
attitude of ah look for aha moments at
every moment in your day I started
keeping a billboard with my staff and
I'm like guys it's getting lopsided look
at all that and I put a little mark
every time I had a good idea for the
business and I'm like I want your side
now more than mine there's no rule that
I have to have all the good ideas be
innovative be innovative read books like
this fine little innovations for your
own life
most people are
patiently impatient which I'm pretty
sure is a recipe for a horrible life
what you have to be is the opposite it
sounds identical to be impatiently
patient versus patiently impatient but
makes all the difference in the world
so what I wish someone had told me I
said look at that like John Wooden said
be quick but not in a hurry 99% of
people do is they act as if they have
all the time in the world so people are
like patient you see people you're like
well when are you going to make your
move on life they're like well you know
I've gotta wait for a few things
together so they're patient but then
when real opportunities arise that they
can identify instead of patiently
waiting and building them step by step
like sculpting a sculpture they hastily
jump into a they don't put the hard work
in they don't build a foundation in the
structure so that's when they are
impatient
what I suggest you try instead is the
exact opposite freak out if you're not
getting the dreams that you wish you had
right so freak out like so today don't
even be don't even say Oh tomorrow I'm
going to get good at this freak out now
but then patiently build so I can just
go through a million things in my life
where I felt pretty one of them is
setting far-off goals when you set a
10-year goal you're just basically
giving yourself an excuse to eight years
into it you're like well I'm still on
track cause I got you know two years
more
no look people write big things make
almost always immediate immediate
action towards the goal once you
immediately freak out
you immediately take action and then
step number two
impatiently move through each cycle and
then and I recommend you can go through
a full cycle Peter Drucker says a good
time frame is 18 months enough time that
things can kick in
but it's not so long thing you lose the
predictive power of gold goals are
trying to get predictive powers over
there in I think lies the happy medium
if you're set in your sixty seven day
goals which are really fast you're
watching us at midnight start at
midnight
forty waiting for me make a slow be
quick but not in a hurry there's this
myth of the solo entrepreneur I'm one
good idea I go out or I'm gonna come up
with his one invention I was just
reading a book i think i was by craig
Venter or one of these big biotech guys
and he said you know there's this huge
myth that they're great breakthroughs
happen from one person having an
individual moment of genius the Steven
Johnson talks about this a lot in his
book where good ideas come from almost
all great ideas come from some
collaborative effect and so the best way
to create a collaborative effect is for
you to take what you know and clone it
out to three or four people or five
people or at least one person even if
you let's say for example hypothetically
you could get two people to know 50% of
what you know to be 50% as effective as
you well guess what two people at 50% is
another one of you and you look out at
the world and you go man all the things
that could be accomplished if I just
could didn't have to sleep and I could
work 24 hours a day or I could go out
there Joel Salatin told me that when he
was here that I I don't have people
sleep with all the opportunities and so
Joel my first mentor he created his
protege was his son Daniel who now runs
the operations and frees Joel up to be
in the big picture and the company their
farm is more successful polyphase
farming Jules able to do other things
you have to be able to do that thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because Tyrell Coleman asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Tai
Lopez's top 10 rules meant the most to
you going to make you think about your
life in your business leave it in the
comments below and I'm going
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
I'll see you soon